معنى من ريف ادلب ايضا سينضم الينا من
ارمناز مراسل الجزيره صهيب الخلف سننتقل
اليه مباشره صهيب للحديث عن مشاهداتك هناك
وماذا عن عمليات الانقاذ عمليات الايواء
محاولات المساعده
بالامكانات المتواضعه والمتوفره في شمال
سوريا
نعم ما عادم وصول مساعدات دوليه تعتمد فرق
الدفاع المدني السوري هنا على مساعده
الناس ومساعده اهل البلده
والتبرعات التي يتم جمعها لتامين الوقود
للاليات التي تعمل على مدار الساعه وايضا
هنا في البلده يتوزع الشبان حول البناء
يحاولون ان يحدثوا اي ثغره بايديهم حتى
يستكشفوا او يسمعوا اي صوت وعند ذلك
يصرخون على الدفاع المدني السوري لي يتولى
عمليات الانقاذ وكذلك اصحاب الجرارات
الزراعيه يقفون بطوابير حول البناء
بانتظار اي جرافه لكي يقوموا بترحيل
الابنيه ترحيل الركام الى مناطق بعيده
ولكن الاحتياجات حقيقه اكبر بكثير وتحتاج
الى جهود اكبر وللحديث عن احتياجات فرق
فرق الانقاذ والناس المشردين ين معي هنا
ريان الاحمد احد العاملين في الشان
الانساني ريان الحمد لله على سلامتكم اول
شيء
احكي لنا عن احتياجات فرق الانقاذ حسب ما
بتشوف انت الوضع صراحه لليوم الثالث على
التوالي فرق الدفاع المدني ومنظمات
المجتمع المدني والاهالي يحاولون ازاله
الانقاذ من فوق العائله اللي تحت الركام
لكن المصيبه صراحه اكبر من حجم الاليات
والمعدات والامكانيات اللي عدنا ما عم
بنشوف ابدا حدا التدخل ما حدا يعني كانه
ما في شيء عنا عم بيصير البيوت اللي تصدعت
واللي قابله للانهيار اهلها كمان طلعوا
منها الهزات مستمره العالم خايفه هاي مع
الوجوهها على العالم صارت بين الزيتون
بالشوارع بهذا البرد الغارس عم بتنام
بالطرقات بالسيارات تحت الزيتون في عالم
راحت على المخيمات المحيطه الان بلشوا
يفتحوا بناء جديد للعوائل
بالكامل تحت الركام في الان اخرج طفل عمره
سنتين ونص
معاش بعد ثلاثه ايام
صارت الاهالي تجيب الجرارات الزراعيه
حتى تشيل
الركام عائلات باكملها
ماتت عندي احد الموظفات توفت كامل اسره
اختها
ما طلع منه هذا اطفال شكرا شكرا
حقيقه الوضع صعب جدا
لا تجد فرق الدفاع المدني الا المسانده من
الاهالي القصص التي نعاينها مؤلمه جدا جدا
الناس
هنا تجمعوا في المدن الحدوديه من مختلف
مناطق سوريا
يعني ممكن ان نجد شاب
يعني
الالم
المنكوبين
مبرر ولكنه يكون الما مضاعفا عندما يتم
التجاهل بهذا الشكل
يعني لا ندري لا ندري ماذا نقول صهيب
فعلا ربما الطريقه وعزائنا وعزائك اي انت
ايضا انك هناك وتنقل لنا الصوره تنقل لنا
حجم الحاجه
للعالم لكي يتحرك
لمسانده هؤلاء المتضررين والذين ما زالوا
يتضررون بسبب احتمال انهيار المزيد من
المتضررين هم هم هم منكبون هم ضحايا هم
جرحى هم تحت الانقاض يعني تحت
تحت الاسمنت تحت الطبقات من الاسم حسن قبل
النشره ونقول كيف سبحان الله رغما ان هناك
اعداد كبيره مئات موجودين تحت الانقاض
ولكن مجرد ان يخرج طفل او يخرج شخص من تحت
الانقاض هناك فرحه عارمه
ولا يمكن ان نتصور مدى
الحاجه لمثل هذه الانباء خصوصا ان هناك
امل
للضحايا لاهالي هؤلاء الذين ما زال
قليلا صهيب